hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fatal frame - now I
apologize for the delay in videos but
after I hit six million subscribers a
lot of things took precedent but now
that I'm gonna be playing it again I'm
also going to be recording daily videos
of this and I'm hoping to record more
than just one a day because this is a
very long game and hopefully it's going
to take a few episodes to get through it
now I say hopefully because this
actually seems like a really good game
I'm glad that so many people are very
eager for me to get through this one I
mean there's a lot of things to like
about the game - because it's a very
creepy atmosphere but what people did
point out was there was actually a
remake of this game for the Wii and I
did not know that at all and it's
supposed to have like better graphics
and whatnot but I don't even know an
original Wii anymore and I don't even
know how I would be able to emulate it
with the motion controls and all that so
I think sticking to the original is
going to be fairly good to be now what
happened now if you case you missed it
from the last one I lost my sister she
went out into the woods or she went out
into the town and she decided that it
was more important to be out there than
to be with her dear sister and so I
shake my head and regretted this
unfortunate scenario but I'm going to be
going out and trying to find her I did
not read what that said I still have not
learned to not spam the X button so I
apologize that I won't be able to read
just about everything that happened but
if you're quick on the pause button you
might be able to find out for yourself
so let's see what other ghostly gastly
deed needs to be done in this town and
what other monstrosity is gonna poke its
head out of me I wonder if I pull my
camera okay so I can't see anything yet
yeah
just a thought of wandering around alone
in a town does not make me very
appreciative of what decisions led up to
this point why the hell am I here why
did all this happen
what does this have to do it what does
this have to do with anything that
happened before we're like in that
flashback in the beginning of the game
they were like younger and they fell and
that's why the sister Mayu
hey hey my my you hey my you my you come
back Mar you I'm running towards you
expeditiously because that's what the
game wants me to do it's only isn't
gonna throw me in a danger or anything
it's totally for your safety and not
mine
my god that camera is not very helpful
with what the hell am i it's so dark
is this supposed to be that dark well I
think maybe yes Mayu that's what I said
that's that thing I said no don't go
into that building full of ghosts don't
even though you're limping I seem to not
be able to keep up
oh okay how's the screw what the hell's
going on I was getting creeped out all
over the place
looks like crimson butterflies I wonder
if that's a clue all righty then don't
you think up on me leave all that's gone
I'm gonna get it real this trap don't
even think about doing nothing
yeah you just stay here you backup
eunuch
almost there almost good Oh perfect Oh
beautiful oh I almost killed you in one
go are not just the best
give me that rifle chuffing no oh god
there's another one hell hey let's go oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa Wow Wow well you
can't just be swinging sticks
willy-nilly I gotta have a moment to
prepare
now oh come on I was gonna get that go
to okay that didn't do it easy that's
the top of your head it's not a very
good picture Oh
currently that's a really good picture I
still don't know the finer mechanics of
this but I'm still gonna just try my
best and I got it that's right back off
I'm the little girl I'm on the edge I
got a camera you're nothing to me all
right so what do we have in store for us
here there was just enough of a
distraction that I couldn't get through
this door in time there are two there
are ornaments on the left and right
doors depicting two people great me and
my sister or some other people you're
talking about he slaughters enormous for
inserting a flat square key so I need to
flat square keys oh boy I get to go
treasure hunting even though my sister
my you got to go in without keys Josh
get the preferential treatment even
though I worked harder in school and I'm
a better student and I'm a better
athlete no my you my you my you that was
a Brady Bunch joke
I hope you guys appreciated that because
I worked really hard on it all right so
where am I supposed to come where am I
supposed to go now I don't know I think
I mean II I might need to go back in
into another building somewhere but
where I don't know oh thank you for
leading me to where I'm supposed to go
hopefully is this gonna be a clues
there's something I'm supposed to go and
do here it's building okay not yet
crimson butterflies this camera is gonna
mess with me because I can't I can't
deal with the sudden transitions did
they go right or left I think they might
have went left because right would just
go back to where I was
I heard something that is a save point
I'll hit that kimsen be saved here for
some reason I like to save points that
are actually logical to what's going on
in the place and not just like oh it's a
lantern here save all of your precious
memories insert them inside as hard as
you can and then you'll be good if you
die maybe although I imagine that if
you're in this town and you have to die
over and over again you'd just be
trapped loop kind of like Silent Hill in
a way but maybe not so much maybe yes
maybe this old Japanese Silent Hill okay
door seems to be locked there I don't
know if the crimson butterflies went
down this way I might be totally wrong
it's just hard to tell cuz everything is
so dark
anybody house that it's a stream well
it's a stream
where am i go i did the the butterflies
did not go this way oh is this the
entrance of the town statue a guard stay
these clothes seemed demand a statues
like this one throughout the village
okay I think I'm going back up the way I
came which is not where I need to go I
need to go the way the butterflies when
I didn't know that they went the other
way because how would I have known when
the cameras would flip floppy on all
over the place many statues just like
that one I know they're beautiful
statues they're glorious statues I would
stand here and admire the statues all
day but I got a game to complete for
people out there that are lovely and
beautiful and a very patient with me
when I go the wrong way completely right
right right guys I mean this is one
where you expect you've watched by alien
within Halley's with it evil within an
alien isolation playthroughs right you
know you know I do a bit of wandering
when I when I when I am stupid and can't
find out where to go shut up everybody
no don't shut up
leave those be anyway well I be a little
more human idle and stalling for there
we go I didn't think I could stall any
longer okay whoa ghost ghost goes to you
my ghost meters tingling no okay maybe
not then I guess that's just a sign that
something supernatural is about to
happen but where am I supposed to go
about all that well that was the house
said I went in I can't possibly be going
back there okay so that's
did I mess up by pulling out my camera I
think I did I was supposed to go down
this way fall in the butterflies it's
just so damn dark I can't see where I'm
supposed to be going cuz that's decrepit
doors have fallen off and you can see
the entire interior oh whoops
oh there they are okay there they are
I'm on my way I'm on my way I'm on my
way babies I'm on the way
hello what have you done for me oh okay
these rocks you wanted me to show these
rocks this dirt this hole on the side
that's how what you wanted yes
okay I'm not entirely stupid
I'm only kind of stupid we get in here
Oh cutscene okay yeah yeah what are you
still doing here
my name is I brah
you are back yeah you inside got to get
out of here
she is at the ceremony masters house she
is going to do it
go get her there's still time to catch
up with her the keys to the gate are
enshrined in twin day teas I just walked
by the great beautiful statues look for
statues like that somewhere in the I
just looked at them they were gorgeous
stop hurry
what thank you can I take a picture of
you you're just so pretty
trapped boy yeah I got that thanks for
captioning that what are you the
Internet
okay so I did that I was looking for the
statues it's a twin carved in many
statues oh I'm supposed to take a
picture and then I get a secret ghost
key for the ghost town and the ghost
locks but that wasn't good enough for
you I need to back up
oh I'm sorry my photography skills
aren't good enough for this game oh
crimson metaphors okay cool so uh
alright ok moving on with my life as if
that life-changing event didn't happen
where are you doing hey hey hi hi hey
you butterfly what are you doing
over here ok if I need to come back I'll
come back back you cannot find a way to
leave the village come and find me I may
be able to help why are you gonna show
me my new life in the village are you
gonna show me a whole new world I don't
know if I like that I don't know if I
like that trapped boy it seems like bad
news I'd better stay away from him no
just capture the affections of my sister
fall in love with her instead of me
stiff not fair
ok hmm so my assumption based on the
story of the game if I'm not actually
talking about the story of the game is
that they're repeating a ritual that
happened a long time ago basically this
town was having a ceremony where these
twins from before like as depicted on
the statue were being I'm guessing
sacrificed or at least one of them was
to honor some God and make sure that
this whole didn't happen something
went horribly wrong it all got dipped
into hell and we're just gonna stay here
for a long time now but I don't know
what all that means and I don't know why
all that is all I know for right now is
that I need to take picture of twin
statues because that's why it whoa zan
film can be equipped by selecting camera
okay is that the more powerful film you
were talking about what's going on over
here huh what's going on over here huh
what's going
what so let's then what's all this then
the examination of the lower portion of
the statues and covers a small wooden
block hey I got the right half of the
key all right whoa hey whoa there sonny
jim wait think you're doing BAM
got you with it happy who's good enough
something to my right fat now got it sis
get up perfect hey no you don't even
think about it yet old ones to me there
y'all beautiful you're ugly but it's
beautiful my pictures beautiful you're
very ugly who else I hear a rumbly some
huh oh oh it's easier it's easy I'm
gonna creepy crawl my way to the big
scoop huh
what have you heard about the village
disappearing what happened all the
snacks why am I so unwelcome here wait I
think you're Jude hey don't look at me
get away I swear I'll shoot I'll shoot
damn it
bass shoot Rebecca whoa whoa whoa hey
almost perfect picture boots back up a
bit
Oh double cell oh no I was confused I
thought if I got double shot it would
have been good der let's back up a
little bit more you guys are
now getting the twinsies over here I can
be the only twin here
what now why I took a picture don't even
think that I didn't take the picture how
are you both still alive
oh I walked into one of them when they
were just crawling on the go okay this
way I look really bad all the time hey
you are you gonna gotcha that did
something to you not enough
there's gonna be an even better one the
last one back gotcha
this whole game place is gonna be me
saint ban all the time the veil I'm like
that one chef that everyone made fun of
back ten years ago yourself ready oh
that was okay now pretty yet but you
will be pretty soon you're so pretty
there you how about that that did
nothing god damn it I'm terrible
oh I got the face I kill them with it
I killed over the side of its vase oh no
I didn't oh god no this combat is
thrilling
I gotta admit man you scrubs you know I
got nothing on me I just found one key
and three of them come out nowhere I
wonder if it isn't even like preferable
to fight him because it's totally
possible that I don't need to actually
fight them so what is all this now
looked around but it doesn't look like
there's a key hidden here okay what
about farther up the path I don't know
if this is the where I originally came
from or if this is just me
I hate it when it goes all black and
white and grainy they're not real
who's really wide-set gentlemen they're
not real could you ask him to stop
banging their tambourine so loudly it's
distracting to me okay so am I supposed
to go up this way or not I don't know
why am i following where the creepy old
men went this will turn out great
gimme gimme gimme i goddamn sacred water
okay so what I need to do I actually
need to use a whip sir
I need to use an item and I need to use
herbal medicine because I need to refill
my strength of it okay that's good
enough that's good enough for now I
probably upgrade my strength at some
point because those ghosts when they
reach into my soul it don't feel good
okay there's something around here what
do we got what are we dealing with here
we'll be looking at what am I looking
for huh my ghost meter was tingling hard
there's got to be something around here
I know there oh I don't know what that
is but I'm taking a picture
oh you look creepy but why what was the
point of that was this one a hit hidden
bonus ghosts did I get bonus ghost
points
looks like you entered the building from
here yeah sure why not I'll probably die
but what do I care at this point
hello
okay
countless talismans with eerie writing
on them are stuck onto the lattice eerie
writing what does that even mean
beyond the lattice you can see a straw
doll lying doll tongue down it's about
the size of a person so it's a mannequin
that's what you're saying there's creepy
writing saying don't come in here you'll
be killed the death by the mannequin got
over here little blue gold glowing items
spirit orb acquired you can equip or
upgrade the camera on the camera okay so
spirit orbs are for upgrading the camera
I'm not gonna do that yet until I know
what to do which you guys are gonna need
to tell me when I'm supposed to do an
old mirror has been enshrined in front
of the altar with a crimson butterfly
picture I was reading comments in the
last one unfortunately there were a few
people that spoiled a few things but
I've been trying to be very selective
and instantly if someone's writing
something like hey you need to do this
because this will happen or cuz I'll
I'll scroll by but I didn't spoil much
so keep your comments going and if you
can please please avoid spoilers that
would be deliciously thankful it's early
I don't know I just cried my eyes out at
a video without they're not but where am
I supposed to go now
am I supposed to do anything about that
straw doll back there maybe I should
take a picture of it could that be a
good thing probably wouldn't infuse it
with the ghosts spirits I've been
capturing horrible medicine okay
probably wouldn't bring it to life I'll
I have an ass hands so I'm just gonna
run wildly into random until I
find the way I'm damned to both go hello
anybody goes to you like okay I don't
know what I'm supposed to do here I
don't know why I'm here anyway I think
I'll just go home now looks like you can
get out here oh yeah
sure why not cuz I don't know why I went
there in the first place I'm looking for
keys I'm not I'll keep this in mind for
later but I'm looking for keys right now
I don't need to worry about all of this
thank you very much I'm gonna do just
fine crying myself to sleep not at the
emotions I feel for my awesome fan base
but the ghosts that are gonna infect my
soul okay
so I guess I gotta go back a BRB uh you
know I've seen a lot of people run I've
seen a lot of people run in a lot of
games and in real life and I can tell
you for a damn certainty this ain't
runnin this ain't running little girl
you need to pick up both feet if both
feet are touching the ground in both
times
you're not running that's actually the
definition Oh Oh sad you almost miss you
you looked all around but didn't look
like icky fudge I gotta keep working not
running
how about you that's the same one I just
loop back to the same one I'm such an
idiot
don't turn around you dingus oh okay
this is back where I was okay all right
no key here but maybe there's another
key up here somewhere there's gotta be
is this guy are you there's butterflies
floating around you I can only imagine
that you've got a key by you hello my
name is me Oh zippers glue small wooden
block yeah I got the left key now it's
gonna take me forever to run all the way
back up the dope dude nobody's there
like a save point around here maybe
please hey what the Jesus God
oh forget me I didn't I didn't even
wanna I apologize for everything
how's it gonna be on my way film to
waste on you guys I think I can't
imagine that I have an unlimited supply
I'll just be on my way
thank you goodbye forever I wonder if
like if I don't shoot those ghosts if
they're just gonna stay there for the
rest of the game and the next time I
need to go through I'm gonna have to
take care of it oh well it's a problem
for future Marc future Marc doesn't mind
dealing with the problems of passmark as
my life has regularly told me wait did I
check this one something on the ground
oh film still not gonna use it screw
that I'm so glad that my ghost cameras
equipped with standard film Oh
well this cutscene wasn't here before
this is cuz I didn't kill the ghost I'm
so sorry
oh this cuz I didn't kill Gus I'm so
sorry oh okay that was just to give me
nightmares cutscene thank you yes I'm
very worried about walking through the
dark streets of LA and then to meeting
ghosts in my own doom at the same time
is that a statue as a statue isn't it
what can't I go to that one alright
whatever fine screw you then I just
wanted a goddamn circle I need to go to
the save point
nevermind I'll say provide I didn't need
to use the same point not that bad oh
well that sounds like a whole mob of
ghosts that sounds like a whole mob of
problems stop going to this random crap
start going to where you need to go okay
that got quiet they shut up they knew
what was good for them this way god the
camera angle changes are just not that
good I got to admit that's my one beef
with this game right now like everything
is fine because I'm totally okay with
controls being a little wonky with like
think now I'll get used to that
oh wait come on I do anything ah that's
a slow on the time and the cameras is
like wonky all over the place I can't I
can't do it okay Q so let's just go fly
my sister and get out of here provide a
boss or something man I know I'm gonna
have to explore the entirety of this
village because I'm assuming that the
game just takes place in this village
alone and I'll have to deal with
everything on a day to day basis but up
until that point arrives I will just
have to understand I am a pawn
I'm the life of the game and I have two
keys that can open this door and somehow
relates to me being twin with my sister
and two twins in the past I'm concerned
the two twin statue keys left indoor
right so what's gonna happen what
happens now
hello oh there's a thing how do I get
that thing do I need to dive headfirst
into the river before I can have that
thank you
herbal medicine thank you very much just
be on my way now
not that I need that because I wouldn't
be bad at this game and allowed ghosts
to chew my face off or anything that
would just be the worst listen I'll just
use my face off what okay well that's
too bad okay we're not gonna explain
that at all there's guys someone's gonna
moan in my ear about how it hurts it's
gonna be totally fine okay never mind
then I didn't see my ghost meter light
up so I didn't think there was gonna be
any oh hi were you the one moaning oh
here I was thinking that my moaning
problems were just my own okay all right
oh
it's Crimson butterfly lantern I need to
know that if I'd have known that it
would have been totally logical that I
was saving a point okay
fine by me all right I think this might
be a serious encounter here okay I mean
if they're putting a safe point like
right beside it hello
oh there was a ghost here there was a
ghost here don't tell me there was not
okay here's the ghost maybe
huh looks almost clear that's not my you
it's not my you why am I locked in here
now I didn't wanna be here okay oh good
flashlight failing Oh No Oh goddamn it
Oh
yeah there's a lot to take in for
dessert oh god those this window Oh
and now the lightning hits let's just
get Frankenstein monster to start
charging up the hill next Dracula can
flutter in in bat form
oh I was right there I know everyone's
gonna be so mad I missed him oh that
wasn't me Oh flowers in the urn are
completely withered and dry they crumble
at your Dutch dance must have been
entertained here one boy at one point
and then they were very unentertaining
when everyone's heard murdering each
other what's they like that sort of
thing it's not a full moon oh no not the
werewolves okay deal with Frankenstein
and Dracula but not the werewolves
anything without look good for kusabi Oh
what about poor me came from the left
her chunk I see you there what are you
doing you sad sack
okay a terrified man but it knows taking
a self-portrait uh-huh huh funny jokes
seriously what the hell is gonna happen
here found some camera equipment in film
instant additional functions okay
detects the fatal frame of the spirit
and signals to you by making the light
in the upper part of the viewfinder
flash red a fatal frame is the most
opportune moment to shoot within a
shutter chance if you capture a fatal
frame a shutter chance will occur during
the blast back shooting again during
this shutter chance creates combo shot
oh yeah that's what I want my
photography Oh small kimono for children
did I just enter the house of the
murdered children I didn't want to enter
the house of the murdered children being
Frank
okay oh did I just black out or white
out oh oh oh no no none of this Max
Payne oh hey excuse me pardon me
pardon I thought it was gonna be like a
hallway Dodger thing whoa
okay can't go that way invisible wall
the RO what didn't the repentance the
resurgence everyone's dead except for me
and let's keep it that way thank you Oh
were you the one moan crying you could
say that she was kimono kimono in moaña
- why are you bloody are the crimson
blood flies blood water flies I can't be
back here
Oh was that not me was that my you I
don't know I wasn't paying close enough
attention even though I was sitting here
with my eyes open blasted like this yeah
I wasn't paying attention enough
apparently okay so yeah what who's that
who's there was there ghosts in that
candle set a candle ghost who's there oh
you okay be the terrified man hello oh
you look like the terrified man Oh
oh you need a few more huh few more no
you're too what are we gonna keep all
these if all these photos were like
saved to your hard drive afterwards you
can just flip through all the memories
this is where I - ography murdered
someone by the name of the terrified man
that was the red flashing in the fatal
frame that was the fatal frame the best
possible shot come on buddy let's go
I know you're still here oh yeah my
camera can detect your soul from miles
away
Fatal Frame bailiff right now yeah
beautiful I'm really sticking it to this
guy I'm getting all of his bad sides all
in one he's so embarrassed by the photos
by the up bobak I wasn't quite
the fatal frame but it's good enough
okay here we go then I won I won I won
the money the money is mine okay why am
i oh no no no no you're not gonna put a
wall with broad hands on it and then
open the door for me inviting me like
come on in have all of your blood
evacuated from your body no thank you
oh it closed on me I thought it opened
holy crap oh man alright then
alright you know it's it's odd because
the scariest moments are not when I'm
facing ghosts and I'm kind of is the
principle of all horror games because
it's like whoa ah back up the
bunny's done nine I lost the money
giddy I'm just gonna go by you but ago
over here I think my sister went maybe
yeah I know you're all creepy iced I
need to do a thing with a person over
here I need to I need to do with I'm
stuck I'm stuck I wanna pick a prick
you laughing at me Lisa can do it huh oh
no oh no don't do that
oh no you're horrible
that's core shot not a fatal frame
gotcha I'm so much better than the last
shot I did that's right
do you recover ah oh she can't get by me
didn't eight hours a day nothing gonna
happen to me
what'd you do huh what'd you do huh
what's that Papa by Megan there your
dashing boots
guy are the felt frame was the fatal
frame had it all over my hands where you
are you turn around okay it's pretty
insane
we're both their fan no ah come on
there's a bunch of baloney she was right
in the frame this is a bunch of baloney
what's he gonna do to me huh you got a
deal huh which way you got to pop up you
gotta come up in between the wall where
I can't see you and then you're gonna
pop out instantaneously and avoid my
shat I see you there man that'll kill
you what you can't do that you can't
just suddenly avoid my shot
oh Jesus
Oh stressful look like the most
stressful one just kept popping up
behind me
man uh there we go okay I'm good now
good it's going here open this door up
find my sis go out home go home
now want to go home floor right that
rock is blinking like a Firefly
something must have someone must have
been standing here is a radio in the
media I'll use the Ray I haven't used
this yet yeah one second okay
Wow
okay all right then you said your what
what are you dad probably
I'm sorry I'm just fighting off the
incredible urge to make inappropriate
jokes that's what I'm doing good he's
going on in this place why do I have a
radio that could listen to Souls okay
so I think that's all I needed for here
now for the eternal quest to finding my
you wherever the hell she went
she's a dingus paper shade lamp has
fallen over no making lamps out of paper
didn't seem like the best idea at the
time I guess they did what they could
with what they had and that rain outside
I think I'm listening to rainy mood
right now or something it's very nice
very soothing and facts oh wait i
justold it myself
oh because it was hard to see that's one
so it's just right in here hey sacred
water that's good I can splash it on my
face prevent the girls from eating them
off
okay I don't know what magical button I
pressed to trigger the cutscene what oh
what you can't fool me those right there
before that's that's a darn why right
there that's a damn lie
okay all right totally normal
oh it's a boss battle apparently bad
okay let's see what I can do for you
okay it's gonna take a lot of work to
make you look good
but I am just a little girl up to the
challenge oh god I panicked
panic none what is that camera obscura
doesn't have any effect well that's a
good sign
that's good sign of swagger face only
for my picture to develop what do I need
to take plenty take Ritchie the floaty
one yeah she's a floaty and fast she's
almost as fast my bill blazing blazing
speed food I got trapped I haven't saved
it forever
oh you're killing me I kidding me I bet
forever Wow
damn it God cute there wasn't a save
point in a while you got throw a one-hit
kill boss at me when you gonna do that
I'll be right back gotcha ha ha I got
you a priest behind don't even think you
can fool me I actually realized this
before but I didn't mention it if I just
hold down the Run button I'll stay in
the direction I'm going even when the
scene transitions so that's gonna be a
lot more helpful to me oh and I was
playing the sister I didn't even notice
okay also I'm gonna upgrade my camera
which is probably very very very very
important so I'm gonna do
also I forgot about the slowdown feature
damn yes
okay did that I powered up that orb good
part of that good this good
I'm very upgraded now I did good I did
good I did good everybody I did good I
did good rest is it good
I think good I feel good about myself I
feel really good I feel really good
like really good here about this oh well
where's that sound ah god damn it was
right next to me with the balls you
can't do that to me that's a bunch of
bull goddamn no no no no no no you don't
get to walk through walls to me no way
to kick it off up your knees take your
picture lady now I know you don't wanna
just take it port or not okay
that's that's something - oh I can't go
back out but how am I gonna save I don't
know how to be her I'm gonna have to do
it all over again if I die if I don't
die I'll be fine but if I die I'll be
good
set the camera no power does that mean
that like it's no power no affecting
where I need to try it better next time
or somehow that it's not good enough now
and then I'm gone okay here we go again
don't let her touch me don't let her
touch me that's this number one rule
don't touch her don't let her touch ya
she's just gotta be an evil person tell
shut by some force okay so I have to
kill her that's just my guess I have to
somehow kill her but I can't let myself
get trapped this is one big loop no it's
not nevermind it's not it's not it's not
maybe something to do with this I don't
know
No am I supposed to know I think I think
every time I take a picture of her she
likes stumbles back maybe there's got to
be something to that cuz even if it's a
low-power she kind of still goes
structions not clear got dick stuck in
goes it was like the side room here but
I don't know if that's gonna be just a
death trap for me probably it is oh
god damn it it is what's the door closed
why do I take the locked over that's
hard
didn't run little girl oh she was like
nobody she was nowhere near a dog what
is this over here what is this what is
this is the door out go around or way
out
go around go around door outdoor if what
the hell is this it's a door I could
have walked out at any moment I could he
just walked out I was actually two feet
from it when I died the first time oh
I'm such an intimate dad I'm sorry about
it
stone mirror Eddy Betty Betty cloths is
filthy from being exposed to the
elements good for the cloth I'm just
frustrated in my own stupidity at this
moment at this juncture I need to
reflect on how much of an idiot I am
whoa what is that
my you i'ma get your butt back here my
you I'm so sick running after you I need
the same point you better be going to a
save Lantern you better be going to a
safe land or else go get the back of a
hand across your butt none not like God
don't be weird it was there something up
here
hey lantern finally god damn finally
okay I got it I got it I'm all over it
guys I'm all over it I'm all over it
I got this I'm good and I'm all that
time so thank you all so much for
joining me for another episode of fatal
frame - there's a really really fun game
I'm having a blast like it may seem like
I'm frustrated points but I'm having the
time of my life playing this is an
amazingly good game and I love it and I
can't wait to see the rest of it then
again tell me what I'm doing wrong
please be nice about it but tell me what
I'm doing wrong in the comments down
below thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next
Oh
blowing basil